i think the words of the president here
were incredibly powerful he spoke
personally about the moral outrage that
he felt which is shared by people all
across the world it does not mean he is
articulating a change in policy it does
not mean he's laying out
a change in u.s policy does he regret
that those words at the very end of the
speech overshadowed a larger message
which obviously put a lot of thought
into in the days
absolutely not he spoke from the heart
is that michael scott and pam
brand new spin from the white house as
they try to walk back their walk back
after president biden walked back his
walk back
over what he said about removing putin
apologies if that sentence just made
your brain walk back
the white house now claiming biden was
speaking in his personal capacity
about russia's president even though
they said he wasn't several times trying
to figure out what biden actually meant
is so confusing that joe actually had to
use note cards just to get his story
straight it even came with the helpful
label tough putin q a talking points in
case he got mixed up with other cards
and if you think this turned into a
total disaster don't worry don lemon's
got the white house covered quite
honestly i think this this is a media
manufactured story i think we should
ease off a little bit because that's not
what the president said he did not say
regime change
okay it's all just manufactured like the
crime wave in hunter's laptop
jesse the personal capacity line yeah
25th amendment right you remember that
yes remember that what was what did
trump say television lion
right
the best scores ever
yeah i don't know this seems a little
more serious this time last time it was
trivial there i think they might have to
stop playing the hail to the chief when
this guy walks in the room because he is
not up to performing the duties we
expect as a commander-in-chief has
anybody seen the raw footage of his
sit-down lunch at the mess hall in
poland with the american soldiers the
media is covering this up but i got to
the bottom oh jeez he walks in the room
and there's no electricity he starts
telling a story about the last time he
went to iraq and saw b biden and he says
oh boo biden wanted to hide his name so
we changed it to hunter
and then
the story never landed and the whole
place was silent and then he just sits
down and gets a piece of pizza and i
remember seeing the footage of bush and
trump you know you go to a mess hall in
a war zone wherever you are and you're
serving the food you're lighting it up
there's selfies everywhere and people
are juiced up this place you could have
heard a pin drop he sits down and he
shoves a piece of pizza in his mouth and
you know what happens next he starts
choking
there was a jalapeno pepper on it and
pepperoni
and
he starts having trouble getting it down
right
and they notice the soldiers notice and
they start assisting him and they start
handing him a glass of water and he sips
on the water and then he starts taking a
napkin
and he rolls up the napkin and he starts
dabbing his forehead and he puts it down
hot pepper there it is there it is now
is this the way you expect the president
united states to act with our soldiers
a couple miles from a hot war with
russia no
you expect more from someone like this
the wheels are falling off wait this
guy's like a vintage car you see the
gauges
the brakes are shot it's no longer fun
to drive it
is now dangerous yeah but you know why
he ate the pizza like that why well leon
panetta gave us the answer yesterday
it's because he's irish
now being irish i'm irish being irish is
now the go-to excuse apparently for
every one of these ridiculous farces and
i thought the moment yesterday when
peter ducey
very calmly as he does brilliantly just
talked him through all the ridiculous
gaffes
then all the ridiculous walk backs and
biden just stared straight at peter
ducey and went none of that happened
we got that tape we have that tape none
of that happened it just didn't happen
he said
there you go it was we got it yeah
that other leaders in the world are
going to start to doubt that america is
back if some of these big things that
you
say on the world stage keep getting
walked back
what's getting walked back it made it
sound like just in the last couple days
uh it sounded like you told us troops
they were going to ukraine
it sounded like you said it was possible
the us would use a chemical weapon and
it sounded like you were calling for
regime change in russia and we know
none of the three occurred
none of the three none of the three i
mean what does it mean none of the three
we heard you say it
but you're the president of the united
states we heard you say each of those
things then we read the walk-backs from
your own administrative white house
press office and then we saw you walking
back the walk-backs and now you've moved
to full denial mode or perhaps more
sinisterly he's moved to completely
forgetting mode yeah but he genuinely
doesn't remember ever saying it could it
be it could have been the hot pepper you
never know
you know judge
i was going to say ask you about you
know having the your most basic ideas on
note cards but i have that written down
as a question so who am i
who am i to judge
judge well i'll tell you this i mean
either he doesn't understand the
consequences of what he said or he
doesn't remember in either case it's
time for the 25th amendment and you know
who has to get involved in the 25th
amendment the vice president kamala
harris would be all in on that one but
but the problem really is that
he's on the world stage he is in a
nation that is literally next door to a
country where there is fighting and
we're on the verge of zelinski thinks
world war iii and when he calls when he
says for god's sake this man cannot
remain in power but crone has to pull
him back they have to have a phone call
the ambassador to nato has to pull it
back these are very dangerous dangerous
times and by the way the russians
themselves are fed up their economy is
shot they're losing people they don't
even know how many people their ruble
doesn't amount to much anymore let's
bounce back
yeah it's it's i actually read that when
did it bounce back today yes it bounced
back it's actually showing uh doing well
against a euro
somebody was watching fbn today
i pretended i read an article oh
you know what that reminds me of
remember when cuomo was getting a little
handsy and he goes hey i'm italian
i just touch people yeah you know uh
dana do you want me to ask you a serious
question you and i both love reading
niall ferguson he believes that the our
white house wants to prolong
to prolong this war to bleed russia dry
but also to defend the ukrainians
because because it's uh satisfies public
opinion but without costing american
lives however
you're risking thousands dead ukrainians
and millions of homeless just to bleed
the country dry that doesn't seem like a
moral stance yeah well one thing i i
want to get to that question but on the
point about the president having note
cards some people have them all right
but one of the things he was saying is
he was expressing a moral outrage right
when you express a moral outrage you
don't need notes exactly because that
comes from the heart i also do not
believe that you can claim that a
president of the united states on the
world stage at a speech that they build
as the most important speech so far that
the president has given in this war
is done in his personal capacity that's
just not believable to me and that's why
the european leaders were like well let
me back away from this and they had to
have that meeting this morning uh to
neil's point neil ferguson yes yes
um the you is silent i think
i i think that what he's talking about
might be the practical result of what's
going on i don't know if it's the
intention
or the strategy because it seems to me
if you wanted to bleed russia dry you
would have started with the sanctions
which would have had the benefit of
possibly deterring this whole situation
in the first place and certainly
zielinski thinks that yes because now
you have a situation where multiple
cities are destroyed you have millions
of people that are displaced you have a
russian economy that is going to be in
dire straits even if the ruble does come
back a bit they are in a terrible
situation but the one thing that biden i
think he does not want to do and we
should not want is for this to continue
because
of the risk of miscalculation or
misrepresentation as you saw in world
war one that led to the killing of
millions which led to the resentments of
the germans which led to the world war
ii all of that could be stopped and
that's why i think that we should be
hopeful that this these talks are at
least are ongoing can i ask one
difficult question because i know this
flies against the general narrative but
at what point
is the red line for our morality right
the west at what point do we watch
maternity hospitals being bombed
refugees being targeted and murdered on
the way out as they try and escape
americans in lines for bread because
they're starving being gunned down
holocaust survivors being incinerated in
their homes as happened last week what
is our red line because we know what
hitler's was and we know when we stood
up to him
i just look at what's going on and i'm
i'm i keep reading that pewter's losing
this is all going badly ukraine and
winning i don't believe any of that i
think putin is doing exactly what he set
out to do
he's ruthless he's barbaric he's getting
more ruthless and more barbaric and
we're all sitting back hiding behind
well he hasn't attacked a nato country
but i bet if he prevails in ukraine and
attacks a nato country what's he going
to say he's going to say
if you come after me i'll use my nukes
and we're going to face the same moral
quandary of a guy taking nuclear
armament
as a protective shield to genocide and i
just asked the question
because at some point we're going to
have to stand up to him
otherwise where does it stop
i'm just throwing that out there all
right good point there you go coming up
chicago's mayor getting extra police
protection after calling to defund the
cops hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else